ورفه طوارئ في ولايه الخرطوم اتكونت
كاستجابة
[موسيقى]
انها تكون موجوده في مراكز الايواء واللي
هي المدارس الحكوميه الجاهزه والمباع
الحكوميه احنا كورس طواري في ولايه
الخرطوم عندنا قصص بتاعه نجاح في التعامل
مع حالات العنف الجنسي اللي حصلت للنساء
في انه احنا عملنا اجلاء امن للشابات اللي
تعرضوا لعنف جنسي وحتى للاسف كان عندنا
بعض منه من من الزهور تمكنا ايضا من اجلاء
المناطق اللي تهجم عليها مليشيات الدام
السريع اجلينا كل المواطنين لمناطق امنه
دي انا بعتبرها قصه نجاح وفخوره جدا انه
اذكرها اوام العالم اجمع طالبين انه يحصل
ضغط دولي على الاطراف المتحاربه لاسكات
البنادق وخفض صوت العنف وخطاب
الكراهيه الموجود حاليا في الساحه
السودانيه و المتضرر الاول منه هو المواطن
السوداني وعمال الاغاثه من الشباب
الموجودين على الارض محتاجين حشد اعلامي
ضخم لتسلط الضوء على القضيه السودانيه بما
يمر به مواطنين السودان من قتل ونهب وسلب
وازلال وانتهاك لحقوق الانسان على كل
المستويات في كل الولايات يعني تس ستاند
فور
سودان